Je suis les choses ont changé depuis que tu as
filmé un Don Quichotte appliqué dans la vie stellaire
aimerais-tu voir n'allez pas au
magasin de ramen
je fais
[Musique]
espèce de paysan fou tu penses pouvoir
me cacher nous aurons de si belles
aventures  ensemble
de la mancha viennent restaurer l'
âge perdu de la chevalerie eh bien j'ai écrit que je peux
lire ce n'est pas comme si tu prononçais les mots
et tu peux regarder les images maintenant il
croit vraiment qu'il est coupable
ça va être chaud
[Musique  ]
Merci Fred mes exploits vieux château les
lit mais tu m'as fait une promesse
je pourrais être quelqu'un tu pourrais être quelqu'un
une [ __ ] de star va essayer d'abandonner le
processus de la fête a besoin d'un
divertissement constant je t'ordonne de libérer
mon écureuil ça  n'a rien à faire,
pourquoi est-ce que tout doit toujours tourner
autour de toi
[Musique]